y ahora vamos a nuestro análisis hoy nos
enfocamos en la juventud y cómo está en
cómo está el panorama luego de las
multitudinarias protestas ciudadanas que
estallaron en el año 2019 con un país
lleno de división política violencia
creciente y teniendo en cuenta el
llamado estallido social donde los
jóvenes tuvieron un papel protagónico
serán ellos el factor determinante para
el tan anhelado cambio que desean en la
política colombiana para ello entonces
quiero dar la bienvenida a lisa trujillo
jazz participante en las protestas del
año pasado 2021 además periodista
independiente y comunicadora popular
defensora de los derechos humanos
gracias a liza por estar con nosotros en
este espacio de directo américa le
pregunta entonces luego de estas
protestas masivas que estallaron en 2019
que ha cambiado en los jóvenes y en la
sociedad colombiana en general a que se
le atribuye este despertar de la
juventud
bueno un gusto estar aquí muchas gracias
por la invitación y de 2019 al 2022 han
cambiado muchas cosas en nuestro país lo
primero fue la formación política de los
jóvenes en el 2019 empezaron unas
movilizaciones por la el para que lo que
nosotros llamamos del paquetazo de duke
en donde estaba incluida una reforma
tributaria luego en el 2021 la que
hicieron impartir la quisiéramos pasar
en el congreso y debido a esto se vuelve
a llamar a la movilización después de un
año de pandemia después de un año en
donde el país creció llegó al 60 por
ciento de la pobreza en sus ciudadanos
en sus habitantes
entonces en el caso de bogotá mucha
gente tuvo que extender un pañuelo rojo
para decir tengo hambre y en el momento
en el que dijo tengo hambre el gobierno
no reaccionó no llegó con subsidios hubo
un escándalo de corrupción por los
subsidios habilitados para la panda para
la pandemia y luego de eso decirle a esa
misma gente que tenía hambre ya que paga
mucho más en la canasta familiar que
tenía que pagar por mucho más por los
servicios funerarios pero que se iba a
quitar se iban a quitar algunos
impuestos por ejemplo la compra de armas
genera un descontento generalizado y lo
que hizo fue que los jóvenes y no
solamente nosotros los jóvenes sino la
gente pobre en general o la gente que
estaba empobreciendo económicamente en
el país saliera a manifestarse y cuando
eso sucedió el gobierno no hizo un
llamado al diálogo el gobierno generó
unas mesas pero mientras esas mesas
estaban con sus respectivos ministros o
delegados en las calles la policía
seguía violentando a la manifestación
nunca hubo una mirada legítima del
gobierno y cuando que hacia nosotros
como una manifestación en el poder del
derecho constitucional de salir a
manifestarnos ya reunirnos políticamente
para pensar no es un mejor país
sí qué pena te interrumpe para que no
quepan todos los temas que quiero tratar
contigo esta ha sido una campaña muy
dividida también lo veíamos en el
informe muchísimos candidatos que buscan
realmente los jóvenes en estas
elecciones legislativas creen que esta
vez las cosas se van a cambiar
nosotros tenemos
un sinsabor porque es que hace cuatro
años las elecciones fueron manipuladas y
el escándalo de los tarjetones de los de
los formatos el 14 estuvieron en todas
partes en redes sociales en donde los
números fueron alterados y no pasó nada
de parte desde el consejo nacional
electoral ni la registraduría y de parte
de nosotros tampoco nosotros estamos
esperando a que este año haya un cambio
en el congreso a que las fuerzas las
fuerzas alternativas logren tener muchos
más escaños pero sabemos que la
maquinaria de los partidos políticos
tradicionales y del organismo en
concreto son muy fuertes y que contra
eso lo que tenemos que hacer es igual
salir a votar masivamente eligen hacer
una veeduría ciudadana muy estricta y un
acompañamiento muy estricto a lo que va
a pasar este 13 de marzo sino solamente
porque se estudian en los candidatos del
congreso sino porque vienen las
consultas interpartidistas en donde si
la representación no está por niño
encontrará cantidad no sé no sé a
francia a márquez que realmente es la
persona ayer vamos decir representa lo
que está pasando en los territorios en
este momento lisa usted hacía una
denuncia y era que el año pasado esas
elecciones según usted fueron pues
digamos adulteradas estuvieron no sé
digamos fraudulentas y tengo la
responsabilidad preguntarle qué pruebas
tiene al respecto para hacer esa
denuncia
bueno las pruebas pues fueron las fotos
que la misma gente que estaba apuntando
y que logró tener los formularios subió
a twitter eso fue una tendencia hace
cuatro años y lo más interesante que
sucedió es que en este país no pasó nada
de hecho hoy en día esos esos
formularios se convirtieron en memes o
en imágenes que invitan a la reflexión y
a la acción de salir a votar y no
permitir que suceda lo mismo que hace
cuatro años en este país hay un fenómeno
también que es muy recurrente y es que
luego de un descontento social y las
protestas multitudinarias ese hartazgo
no se ve realmente reflejado en las
urnas en esta oportunidad cree que si lo
vamos a ver reflejado en el voto
esperemos que si nosotros estamos
haciendo una campaña muy fuerte para que
todos todos nuestros jóvenes que
salieron a manifestarse y todas esas
personas de todas las edades que
salieron a manifestarse que están
posibilitadas para ir a votar que son
los 18 años en adelante lo hagan lo que
sucede es que no es como que nosotros
tengamos el descontento o la incapacidad
de ir a votar sino que es muy difícil
cuando sabemos a lo que nos enfrentamos
a salir a votar pero luego era un
formulario que tienen los números
alterados y ver algunos montados de
votación que lo permite entonces
nosotros vamos a salir a votar el cambio
también que se ha visto que los jóvenes
se han organizado mucho más se han
creado colectivos se han creado
organizaciones se han creado distintas
maneras de poder de poder ponernos de
acuerdo y una de las cosas en las que
estamos de acuerdo es que contra todos
los pronósticos debemos salir a votar
este 13 de marzo tanto al congreso como
a las consultas interpartidistas
también el año pasado hubo elecciones
para los consejos de la en colombia se
siente representados ustedes los jóvenes
en el colectivo de jóvenes también que
suben las protestas con estos comicios
que el año pasado
bueno la mayoría de los jóvenes que
quedaron
pertenecen a partidos como el partido
liberal como el partido de la u algunos
del pacto histórico las
representatividades que pudieron
participar en estas elecciones desde las
organizaciones del movimiento social o
desde las organizaciones juveniles que
nacieron a partir de la primera línea y
tuvieron un algunos escaños pero no se
logró una mayoría entonces digamos que
nosotros estamos en un camino que
entonces sabemos que tenemos que evitar
ir dando paso a paso este fue un primer
paso no logramos todos los consejeros de
juventud que hubiéramos querido en esos
consejos municipales y locales pero
estamos en ese camino de la construcción
de un criterio político de nosotros los
jóvenes y en eso vamos también lisa le
quiero preguntar que le quería preguntar
cuáles son esos cambios sustanciales de
ustedes los jóvenes que deben ocurrir en
colombia para que cambien las cosas para
que no se sientan a lo mejor excluidos
para que se sientan en un país que si
tiene y oportunidades de crecimiento que
si tiene unas oportunidades de futuro
mire este es un país que tiene una
constitución muy linda que tiene una
constitución que ha enmarcado una
cantidad de derechos fundamentales y
otros derechos que se le dan a uno un
listado de necesidades que el estado
debe suplir y nosotros no conocíamos eso
muchos jóvenes no conocían esa
constitución entonces el papel
fundamental que se está dando ahora es
el entendimiento de que acá nadie estaba
pidiendo como como lo denunció mucho
tiempo el ministro de defensa está diego
molano de
detener un cambio con un cambio completo
en la política y en la economía del país
hacia el uno mismo sino que nosotros lo
que estábamos y lo que seguimos haciendo
es exigir el cumplimiento de esa
constitución el estado debe suplir
cuatro necesidades básicas en este país
que son la vivienda el alimento la
educación y la salud y resulta que acá
la gente se muere haciendo filas en los
hospitales para un servicio de necesidad
prioritaria qué es la salud entonces lo
que nosotros establo que nosotros
tenemos en este momento que hacer es
seguir en la defensa de esos derechos
conocer cada día más las herramientas
legales que nos ha dado esa constitución
del 91 pero también eso es
ese apoyo ese acompañamiento y esas
sentencias que ha dado la corte
constitucional frente a nuestras
demandas para seguir exigiendo al estado
que cumpla no solamente en las ciudades
en lo urbano sino en los territorios que
son los más afectados por la violencia
por el conflicto latente que sigue en
este país
brevemente ya para finalizar a nuestra
conversación liza le quiero preguntar en
conclusión cómo llega entonces la
juventud a estas elecciones muy
brevemente
yo creo que la juventud llega en un
punto en donde tiene mucho miedo porque
ya no podemos manifestarnos el gobierno
sancionó la ley 21 75 del 2022 de la ley
de seguridad ciudadana eso quiere decir
que los espacios que nosotros teníamos
de manifestación eran prácticamente ya
no existen son hostigados por la fuerza
pública porque se les dio herramientas a
la fuerza pública para hacerlo pero
también tenemos una convicción muy
importante y es que tenemos una única
oportunidad en el straits 2022 de
cambiar la política de este país de
cambiar a las personas que han estado
durante años atornillados en el
congreso- durmiendo comiendo como lo
haremos por muchos vídeos sino haciendo
su trabajo queremos personas que hagan
su trabajo y queremos un presidente o
una presidenta que vele por las
necesidades del pueblo entonces nosotros
llegamos este año a las elecciones con
la convicción de lograr ese país para la
vida y para la vida digna que tanto es
para exigimos desde el 2010 imagen